uh how hard is it to reach what are the
what are the requirements for
Grandmaster by the way because yeah and
what are the requirements for
international Mastery you mentioned a
few requirements and so on yes so the
first one is you have to know how to use
a sure mic and an arm
um slowly you were impressed by the
share microphone by the way for the for
people listening we're using this uh as
some sure sm7b that a lot of podcasters
use
I don't know why and Michael uh Jackson
on Thriller which Grimes told me really
that's why I think it looked a little
different but it's the same wow
underneath it a few musicians used it in
studio I don't know where it became
popular as a as a podcast and microphone
because I think most broadcasters use
condenser mics that look like really
fancy yeah this looks a little and else
one's great it sounds really really good
and I told you before that I wanted to
use it but it requires a external
dashboard of some sort and I'm
way too lazy to learn how to do it and
my microphone doesn't sound that bad for
YouTube and for for twitch but this is a
long term I still have to figure out how
to stream stuff I'm not I haven't
figured that out because you want to go
down into the world of twitch no I don't
okay I don't you just want to learn how
to do it uh uh no for uh
do you know what we have over there so
first of all yes it is it's like uh
I feel like The Hobbit going into like
mortar like I I yeah twitch is a very
intense world but the there's useful
cases when you should have your
microphone
work with like
the different the processing chain work
in real time so you can do like
interviews
and also I play video I try to play a
video game once a month so
um I've done that like three times
already
uh so stream that kind of stuff for like
like an hour uh like play Skyrim I like
I love playing Skyrim I actually love
the idea I haven't done that yet but
apparently in Skyrim you can turn off
the monsters
you could just walk around
so I love the idea of just walking
around Skyrim for a couple hours and
just like because it's beautiful nature
I see have you do you know anything
about those uh I know I I know I know a
little about Skyrim uh but so it's kind
of like chat no
sure yeah it's just beautiful worlds so
um
there's games that are able to create
this sense of you know the way you feel
when you go hiking a sense of nature
yeah there it's not that they're ultra
realistic but they capture some Majestic
aspect of nature I think some of it is
also music something peaceful it's like
old-timey uh medieval type of music
and just the trees like the wind like
you could and then there's in in the
distance there's the mountains and you
can like you have a sense of history
that the nature gives you you have a
sense of space like this you're like
this tiny little creature and there's
this big world all around you I don't
know how it that's like an art for a
video game to create that it's not just
about the monsters in front of you yeah
it's about this world and this feeling
of a world so I can just walk around and
enjoy it I get asked this question a lot
why don't why don't I stream more video
games yes and
I didn't know that such video games
first of all existed I thought it was
mostly just
various sci-fi-ish characters and
shooting and uh objective yeah yeah I've
played OverWatch on stream it's the it's
the only video game I actually played a
lot and got decent at and I couldn't
play it on stream anymore because my
teammates would use racial slurs in the
voice chat yeah so that is
one of the because I've been thinking of
talking to a few uh streamers and they
do
they're a little bit I I don't know as
far as they the the that Community
broadly does use racial slurs and seem
to make them okay
um but for the ones I would talk to are
a little bit they're just harsh in
general in in the intensity of language
and I don't know what to feel like I
don't want to be the guy who says like
kids these days with their with their
mean language on the internet like you
want to kind of adapt to the different
communities but at the same time
there is there's lines that you can
cross right like if you make everything
into a joke
because that's what they kind of do
everything ends in LOL everything is
funny yeah and that becomes
uh once again a lubricant
that uh it's like a slippery slope that
takes you to a place where you actually
make
pretty
um mean ideas even evil ideas okay
because the star is a joke
and so I mean you start getting into the
territory of I mean because I've been
reading a lot on Hitler and and Stalin
and so on and you'll see those kinds of
topics come up in that community and
it's like oh they have a very different
perspective on that stuff and to them
it's just a fun fun joke fun time and I
I and I see that the contrast of that
with Call of Duty where you're where
you're shooting and I I
love shooting and killing things in
video games but there's a slippery slope
there too because then just having
visited the front in Ukraine you get to
see the real killing of people
and you see how one can lead to another
it it's not an obvious but
there's a
there's something that happens in video
games where you're like well this is not
reality
the same kind of things happens in war
well the people on the other side aren't
really human it does become a kind of
video game and that that same mechanism
I feel like I want to be cautious about
our brain going down that road
so yeah I
I do worry about that Community
um
but there are video games that don't
have such communities around them I
think Skyrim I don't think Skyrim is an
online component of people Minecraft I
think is relatively civil
from what I've seen interesting a good
Community I think it's a lot of a lot of
right now it's booming it's a lot of
young creators who are all seemingly
quite close
and
but I think the community then extends
to social media some of them are intense
but who isn't
and I think I think they Foster a more
or less kind of good group of folks but
no I I completely agree I think a lot of
that stuff and combined with the
anonymity stuff that we mentioned
earlier totally dehumanizes the way
people interact with each other and it's
it's scary I don't
I don't know
combine that with two years of some
people barely going outside
yeah yeah it's not a good mix it's not a
good mix at all I mean you'd like to
think that folks it's like in their
teenage years kind of go through those
and they mature out of it and stuff so
like they they they they start to
realize the weight of their words like
that's my hope but we're all trying to
figure that out
how the internet has changed youth
like easy access to porn easy access to
like some dark communities yeah where
dark ideas uh breed
I don't know
but then again I trust in the goodness
and the intelligence of people at the
end of the day and I think kids will
not sound like an old man but it's it's
good for kids to play with different
ideas and then they grow out of it
hopefully but then you have to have
parents in good school and like good
friends that kind of call them out and
they're [ __ ] you need that if you're
stuck in inside
under anonymity maybe you don't have
some of those signals